Today we're trying different sports
with the wrong ball!
First up
Ping pong with a golf ball!
Oh, this works well!
Yeah it's...
Hey guys
Try this one!
*Throws bowling ball*
WHAAAT!?
Yeah just try it out!
I'm sure it works!
Next up, volleyball!
Let's play a match against Lassi and Emil
What's our tactic?
I'll do all the diving!
I'll do the saving
and then you finish it!
To ten points
Here we go!
Yeah now we get it!
Okay Otto!
Yes!
You take?
Wooow!
Nice Miikka!
You take!
Nice!
Oh that's me!
You!
Nooo!
Emil!
What are you doing down there?
Okay Otto let's finish them!
Still in play!
Noooo!
Ten different sports
Ten different free kicks
Me against Lassi!
Yes!
That was a professional fake!
This is an easy one
Noo!!
Volleyball!
Oh what a save!
I think you can directly
just give up on this one
No way!
No
He's not going to save that one!
Oh, this is easy!
In the face!
The bowling ball!
Adrenaline where are you?
You saved it like it was nothing!
Oh no!
Yeah you almost saved it!
You ready Lassi?
Yeah I'm ready!
Check this save
Look at this!
Okay Lassi it all comes down to this one!
I know!
No it slipped!
You can hop in for one
I'll kick it from really far!
Basketball with an American football
First try!
Okay
That was a bit too easy!
Basketball frisbee
Okay
It's football's turn!
Bam!
Baseball
Basketball
Woow!
That took a while!
Next one!
Let's try which ball works best for tennis!
Serve with the bouncy ball
You don't wanna be here?
No, I don't!
I definitely don't want to be here!
A bit dangerous maybe?
Where did it go!?
Wooooow!?
What!?
How is that possible?
And the extreme
bouncy ball - baseball shot
Make sure to watch until the end!
We're going to need some
bigger balls
for this one!
Super bouncy ball!
Straight in the face!
It's three times
bigger than the racket
Oh, nice!
Come on!
It's still in play Emil!
This is the best ball so far!
Yes!
Winner!
Fun and tough!
But that's why it's called
an exercise ball!
We are out here on the golf course
and we're going to draw
which ball each one of us gets!
American football
Volleyball!
Table tennis ball!
My ball is the only one
that actually fits in the hole!
It's the wrong way!
My shot
I can do however I like!
Good shot Miikka!
I'll go with an iron
Show it!
It's continuing into the forest!
That's in a good place!
Whoa!
Look at that!
Calculated shot!
I could say that it's not Miikka
who's winning this!
Fourth shot..
Yes!
I think that's my best shot so far
No way!
Good shot!
No, no, no, no!
That doesn't count!
Whoah
Your best one!
At least I look like a pro golfer
don't I?
No!
Come on!
It bounced over the sandpit
This is clearly a shot for that racket
Thanks Miikka!
Good caddying!
No!
Hit the tree!
Behind the trunk!
He's for sure
going to hit the stump
Are you 100% sure?
Yeah
I'd like to say 200
Oh, he got it!
It went over!
Very proud of you Emil!
That was very good
How did I get it too far!?
You got to have it land in the hole
I don't think so Miikka
It's golf Emil
Have you played golf before?
You've got to get it in the hole!
True, that's true
Now the next one
you just have to lift it!
My turn?
I mean that's probably the rule
Shoot him away!
Now it's Miikka
Let's take it home!
Not the amount of shots
Yeeesss!!
Now it's your time
to win the game
Well done Otto!
The winner!
Let's move away from here
Squash!
With a floorball!
It's so broken!
Look at this!
Bouncy ball is pure chaos!
It went through all the walls!
I was like:
I'm hitting it over there
it can't end up here!
It looks very dangerous
What is going on!?
It's going to come here
Like I said!
Welcome to the box!
Okay go!
That was..
It sounds very risky!
You broke the chair!
I was just testing
if the bench works!
I think I'm done with this...
Maybe that's dangerous enough!
So next up
we're going to try baseball!
We have an ex-professional hitter
And a professional catcher
I'm good!
First ball
shuttlecock!
Touchdown!
No home run?
Hockey puck!
You're hitting them quite well
so I'd say we move on
to more difficult ones
I'll try and catch it!
Yeah!
American football!
Whoah!
We've got it pretty far with the other balls
but I think the bouncy ball
should be
the one that takes the victory
I think this white line
is a good goal
Like if we can get it here
that must be like 150 meters
You ready Otto?
Go!
I found a bouncy ball
200 meters away
from the hitting area!
I think this might go the furthest
if I can get a clean hit on it
I think there is a text on the golf ball
It says..
I think it says
Subscribe!
Subscribe to Pongfinity!
Do it!
Ready!
Set!
Go!
Whoah!
Where did it go?
It went out the court!
Really it did?
Yeah
Luckily it didn't go on the buildings!
I sliced it!
That could have been lethal!
The winner of the baseball challenge
was:
the bouncy ball!
Or the golf ball!
Oh wait Otto
we still have the bowling ball!
Okay!